essa pergunta o que faz você se sentir
vivo vem me acompanhando há muito tempo
sempre tive essa curiosidade o que faz
as pessoas sentirem que elas estão vivas
no corpo e nas idéias no corpo na
experiência
isso começou quando eu era estudante de
biologia eu adorava a natureza mas eu
achava as aulas meio estranhas e e eu
buscava refúgio num pequeno fragmento de
mata atlântica que pertencia ao
instituto de biociências onde estudava
eu ficava lá contemplando sentindo
aquele estado permanente de
provisoriedade aquela coisa o tempo todo
se transformando e cheio de energia
cheio de vitalidade eu me sentia muito
bem e me sentia viva naquela experiência
e eu percebia que aquilo que estava
aprendendo na faculdade não ia me ajudar
a entender aquele fenômeno aquela força
aquela complexidade que eu vivia ali
porque simplesmente porque nas ciências
biológicas não se olha pra isso não não
é assim que se vê nas ciências
biológicas a gente estuda os seres vivos
tirando lhes a vida e buscando enquadrá
los nos esquemas de classificação
previamente estabelecidos
é esse tipo de de pensamento que separa
ao todo em partes e que separa o
observador do observado e recebe um dos
nomes né de mecanicismo ele considera
que nós não fazemos parte da natureza
é claro que esse tipo de pensamento nos
trouxe muitas vantagens
todo o desenvolvimento da teoria das
tecnologias de que hoje desfrutamos foi
possível ser desenvolvido por meio desse
tipo de pensamento mas a relação com a
vida percepção do vivo é foi ficando
menos valorizada foi ficando para trás e
hoje em dia raramente fazem parte dos
processos educacionais ou da percepção
viva no cotidiano das pessoas
tem muito jeito da gente se sentir vivo
eu acho que você pode estar cansado pode
estar com sono pode estar com frio e é
cada um de um jeito eu queria pegar um
exemplo é de algo que todos nós estamos
fazendo juntos nesse momento que é
respirar
todos nós estamos respirando o ar que
respiramos é formado por
majoritariamente nitrogênio e 21% de
oxigênio além de outros gases presentes
em menores quantidades
esse oxigênio não estava presente na
atmosfera da terra quando ela começou a
se formar
depois de alguns milhões de anos
alguns seres microscópicos começaram a
fazer uma reação química diferente
começaram a captar os gases que estavam
naquela atmosfera daquela época fazer
essa reação química que a gente hoje
chama de fotossíntese e liberar oxigênio
e levou um milhão de anos para a
atmosfera começar a ficar preenchida de
se o desses desse oxigênio a uma dada
altura teve uma explosão de vida e aí
todos os bilhares de diferentes espécies
que emergiram ajudaram a controlar a
taxa de dsts gênio da atmosfera então
aqueles produzindo aqueles respirando e
consumindo oxigênio de forma que a gente
há muito tempo tem uma taxa estável e
foi assim que as espécies foram se
diversificando e evoluindo mas hoje em
dia há a nós todos todos nós humanos e
todos os outros seres vivos precisamos
exatamente dessa taxa de 21% de oxigênio
na atmosfera que é proporcionada pela
ação do metabolismo de todos os seres
vivos
então nós somos dependentes deles então
numa simples respiração
a gente está conectado com eles neste
momento todos os que estão presentes na
terra neste momento e todos os que
fizeram parte da nossa história que
tivesse um pouco mais de oxigênio agente
kay maria e se tivesse menos a gente se
asfixiaria então é uma é uma relação
muito evidente e nem de ddd relação viva
num existem claro muitos outros exemplos
mas isso é um exemplo bem é dramático de
quanto que nós inter somos com todos os
seres no tempo e no espaço
quando eu era estudante e e eu me
refugiava na mata da era como que quase
que para me curar deste mecanismo
radical que é desconsidera os
sentimentos a os sentidos as emoções as
intuições
mas o meu corpo sabia daquelas relações
eu é que não ainda não tinha
desenvolvido consciência e assim a mim
pois eu não me abandonou
quando minha filha nasceu eu levei um
susto
eu percebi no meu colo toda a o fluxo da
vida vindo na minha direção desde há
muitas eras e aí eu percebi o meu leite
dando continuidade àquele fluxo sem fim
foi uma experiência muito transformadora
para mim
desde então eu comecei a buscar outras
formas de entender a natureza formas
mais integradoras que hoje nós
englobamos sob o nome de ciências
holísticas eu não sabia naquela época e
fui aprendendo com o tempo que era uma
ideia de natureza que me incomodava e
que a idéia de natureza que o povo tem
de definir a sua ação sobre ana e que
essa ideia vem mudando desde o início da
jornada humana no planeta
então ela não é uma verdade estabelecida
essa idéia de natureza que prevalece
hoje
permite a gente considerar a natureza
como uma máquina como um recurso que que
a gente que coloca a ela nosso serviço
submete diz desequilíbrio destrói
é essa a ideia de natureza que faz com
que a gente costuma sociedade é injusta
desequilibrada com pessoas com relações
utilitários entre si e com o mundo
essa idéia de natureza nos autoriza a
eliminar ecossistemas inteiros distingue
espécies como a idéia como a desse é
desde o reino seront grampo que morreu
há algumas semanas atrás e ele era o
último representante vivo dessa espécie
a espécie acabou
será que isso não tem nenhuma
importância para nós será que esse ano
não nos toca
será que isso não não nos afeta
como é que a gente lida com o
desaparecimento de uma espécie que levou
milhões de anos
pra se expressar
então apesar da gente viver dessa forma
a realidade viva continua agindo sobre
nós
eu tenho uma convicção de que a gente
consegue fazer uma mudança nesse nosso
jeito de pensar
mas aí para isso precisa de um esforço
precisa de uma intenção
a gente precisa voltar a esse contato
direto e sensível com a natureza
perceber sentir o fluxo da vida fluindo
em nós porque nós somos natureza e
quando em contato com os outros seres
prestar atenção pra estar profundamente
a tensão entrar no tempo em que a vida
funciona um tempo que nós somos nós
somos natureza
vamos dar um exemplo imagine que você
está observando um botão de flor
então você se dedica a a afastar os
pensamentos e fica concentrado ali
observando aquele botão de flor
esse botão de flor está se movendo mais
uma velocidade e perceptível para os
nossos sentidos
mas se você olhar profundamente você vê
que ele está se movendo você sabe que
ele está se movendo e aí você vai
perceber que você também está se movendo
porque aquela força que impulsiona o
botão a se abrir é a mesma força que
está pulsando em você e que está te
levando para alguma direção então esse
exercício de de mudança de percepção ele
ele pode nos ajudar a nos libertar desse
condicionamento de um jeito de ver o
mundo como se ele fosse mecânico e duro
enquanto a gente sente vivencia a
fluidez a interação a profunda
comunicação entre todos os seres com os
quais compartilhamos esse lugar tão
fascinante como o planeta em que vivemos
e ao integrarmos essa relação ao recuar
nos reconciliarmos com ela com a
natureza
vamos fazer como fizeram nossos
ancestrais e como fazem ainda os nossos
povos originárias resgatando uma relação
de pertencimento de amor de
reciprocidade uma relação de saúde
equilíbrio e bem estar
as nossas crianças precisam ser livres
para brincar com a natureza
os pais e educadores precisam saber ouvi
las e respeitar a natureza delas porque
cada bebê que nasce cada um deles é a
natureza se expressando desta vez na
forma humana
se você deseja que o seu filho seja um
adulto bem sucedido deve permitir que
ele tem uma infância bem sucedida e esse
pique significa que ele possa brincar
ser livre e solto com a natureza
eu acredito também que para a gente é e
raiza a essa mudança de jeito de olhar o
mundo aqui as vivências com a natureza
precisariam fazer parte de todo tipo de
formação profissional e todo mundo que
empreender esse processo de transição
formar grupos estamos juntos temos força
para mudar os nossos modos de vida
porque as coisas no fim as grandes
mudanças relação muito simples e estão
ali ao nosso alcance
ao fazermos assim vamos nos conectar
vamos poder responder à pergunta inicial
você se lembra qual era o que faz você
se sentir vivo
ao entrar em contato direto e profundo
com a natureza
você vai poder ir além da percepção dos
elementos que circulam em nós é uma
percepção mais sutil e ampla que nos
deixa cheios de vitalidade e livres para
brincar com a terra
obrigada